un nuevo episodio de violencia en
afganistán tras un ataque suicida en
kandahar en el sur del país con varias
explosiones en una mezquita chiita
durante la hora del tradicional rezo de
los viernes
los disparos empezaron después de
terminar las oraciones luego se
produjeron dos o tres explosiones nos
lanzaron contra una ventana muchas
personas martirizadas o heridas estaban
allí tiradas no sé qué pasó después
este episodio se da una semana después
de un ataque similar en la región
norteña de kunduz contra una mezquita
también chiíta que dejó al menos 80
muertos y cerca de un centenar de
heridos y fue reivindicado por el grupo
terrorista estado islámico
ahora el golpes contra cantar el corazón
religioso de los talibanes en lo que
parece una acción contra el nuevo
gobierno justo el mismo día que se
cumplen dos meses desde la llegada de
los talibanes al poder el conflicto
entre la facción talibán y la filial
afgana del estado islámico está en
activo desde 2015 y es un reto más para
el ejecutivo que en estos momentos está
luchando por el récord internacional
además del repunte de la violencia en
todo el país afganistán enfrenta una
creciente crisis política sanitaria y
económica que pone en riesgo de pobreza
y hambre a millones de personas